[Music]
okay so as introduced Dominic levy I'm
working for Linkara company and today I
would like to tell you a couple of works
words on neural networks and with a
special focus on activation functions
okay so a couple of words lots of
promotion I'm trying to juggle both
professional career working at Linkara
at a company that does a lot of services
connected to the data science world from
warehousing to to reporting user
experience and so on I work at the
department that focuses on data science
in machine learning and from the
academic perspective I push through my
PhD degree where I focus on neural
networks especially especially okay why
I selected such a topic you know
networks are like a very big big topic
and why activation functions so there
are many hyper parameters that we can
tune when have been talking about you
know networks the architecture the
number of layers the depth of the neural
net in other words as well as the number
of neurons even the whole active
architecture because there are different
types convolutional neural networks
recurring like long short long term and
short term memory so there are also the
learning crates the techniques for
initializing weights so there are simply
so many that I had to start somewhere
and as I'm a curious mind I simply focus
at the activation functions at the
beginning so I'm actually happy I don't
know if you have seen the previous
lecture which told you a bit about
gradients and the back propagation I
also want to make a small introduction
into this topic because it's going to be
necessary when comparing different
activation functions so here
like a very simple neural net one that
has three layers and input/output and
one hidden layers and two neurons in
each layer I would like to walk you
step-by-step on on the forward pass on
how the the prediction of the the
network is calculated so if we focus on
a particular neuron like for example the
h1 the the first neuron the hidden layer
we can see that this is a combination of
linear input so in this case that the
net value so the input to this neuron
this is actually the equation that you
can see here it's a linear combination
of the weights and the inputs plus the
de bias term then this is put through an
activation function and this is
something I'm going to focus on today
and the the value is like forwarded for
the net so that we finally arrive at the
prediction and the same analogy goes for
the output layer where instead of
thinking the input we take the output of
the hidden layer okay so we know how to
calculate the prediction but in order to
predict something we first have to know
the correct weights and in order to do
that we need to train this neural
network and in order to do this we need
to have like an objective and in the in
this case it's the error function which
we which we are trying to minimize when
learning what are the correct weights so
in this case of this simple neural
network the error is simply a sum of the
errors of each of the output neuron okay
so going into the back propagation
algorithm the intuition behind this is
that we want update the weight in such a
way that we minimize the error of the
function and this is done through back
propagation so the calculation of a
gradient we want to know what's the
impact like the the influence of
changing weight
in this case this is an example wait
five on the value of total error and
weakest we can do this using the chain
rule so if we try to decompose the the
influence into like particular steps we
can see that actually it's the
derivative of the error with respects to
the output of the neuron and times the
output the derivative of the output with
respect to the net value and the
derivative of the net value with respect
to the weight so here we are talking
about this this part of the neural net
when we go deeper into the net the
equation becomes longer it's not more
complicated it's simply longer because
we are still using the chain rule so
it's like simple operations but the the
deeper the net the the more time the
activation function appears somewhere in
there okay so going into the topic that
the actual topic I would like to compare
a couple of activation functions in
during this presentation and the
identity function it's like a comparison
for me that the benchmark so it's not
actually a function that I want to show
differences based on on this one so some
properties of this function it has a
constant value of gradient but the the
main like disadvantage here is that we
used the ability to to stack layers
because when using activation this
identity function the we do not
introduce non-linearity into the model
so basically no matter how many layers
we stack this still going to be a linear
transformation but the function that
actually started the whole neural
network revolution the sigmoid function
it's a function that has like a nice
interpretation in terms of in terms of
probability because it's from 0 to 1 it
also has the analogy to to to brain
because it either activates or not like
neurons in the brain buzz but as it was
the beginning of this whole history it
has a lot of disadvantages like for
example it has like pretty small
gradient value and this I will arrabal
elaborate more on on the next slide when
I will will be talking about the problem
of vanishing gradient but another
disadvantage of this function is the
problem of saturated neurons so whenever
we have input value of like less than
minus 10 or greater than 10 you can see
that the the gradient will be almost
zero so no learning will take place so
the neuron will become saturated and
that the weights will not be updated so
this might be a problem when we are
trying to resolve a problem and our net
is simply not learning ok as I promised
that the vanishing gradient problem so
as I told you the more layers we have
the more times the activation function
appears so looking at like an example
with free neural networks each one
having more hidden layers we can see
that the more times the activation
function appears the lower the update of
the weights will be and this is because
even if the in the best case scenario we
will have the gradient equal to 1/4 so
if we lose the chain rule and we like
calculate the upstream gradient to those
layers closer to the beginning of the
net the value will be very small so that
will be harder to train the neural
network ok the first paragraph I covered
the the analogy to brain and a nice
interpretation but there is also one
more problem with this sigmoid function
it's not 0 centered so we have the
output that is always in the range
between 0 and 1 and this can lead to
suboptimal learning
because if our if our output function is
always output value is always in the
range of between zero and one it's
always positive and as we can see it's a
vital part of that of the way we
calculate the influence of weight v on
the error okay so what's the basic thing
I wanted to highlight here this is the
part that is common for all the weights
so this is the upstream gradient so all
the weights that we are that are coming
into this neuron will share this part of
the equation so and this is specific for
a particular neuron so when all the
neurons have output a positive output it
will be always design the positive sign
so the actual update of the weight in
case of this function will depend only
on the sign of the upstream gradient
which is the same for all the weights so
this will lead to a situation where we
either increase all the weights or
decrease all the weights and if the
optimal situation would be to increase
some and decrease others this leads to a
situation where the learning path is
suboptimal and I try to depict in a
visual like instead of going through the
perfect the learning rate we sorry the
perfect direction we are like increasing
everything decreasing all the way it's
increasing decreasing so it's like more
zigzagging okay the hyperbolic tangent
it's another common activation function
that is used in neural networks so it is
a function that resolves some of the
problems of the sigmoid function it's
basically a scaled version of this
function and first of all it has higher
value of the gradient so it's easier to
train it because it's harder to
for the problem of vanishing gradient to
appear and it's also zero centered so we
do not have this problem of suboptimal
learning curve but the problem that
still stays is the one connected to the
saturated neurons so whenever we have a
input value of less than minus 10 or
greater than 10 the neurons become
saturated and almost no learning takes
place and like finally we arrive at
something that is used nowadays
something that can that is applied like
instead of the art approaches they
rectified linear unit which is basically
a combination of tooling linear
functions and now previously using the
the other functions I elaborated a lot
about you know theoretical why is it
like that and we could derive this from
equations in case of dysfunction it's
more like experimental results tell us
that it's actually much better it
performs better so for example the
convergence so the time we need to
achieve good result a high accuracy is
lower for this function versus the
function that I described previously
it's also less computationally expensive
because previously we had to calculate
some complex functions and now we simply
threshold the matrix at zero but it also
has its drawbacks minor ones but still
in case of rectified linear units we
need to monitor for that neurons and
what I mean by lead by that neurons so
whenever we have input like observation
or or we initialize the weights
incorrectly and we fall into the this
area whenever the output value is zero
this neuron will simply not take take
place in will not take will simply not
activate so it will not take any like
meaning in in the network
but like in the academic community or
even in the professional community
people argue whether it's actually a
disadvantage or whether it's an
advantage because this can introduce
sparsity into the net so it's like so we
need to train less neurons simply and
then the net becomes more robust in this
way the other nice things a nice thing
about this is that this function has a
lot of variations like for example EQ
ello which I'm depicting here which is
which is a simple term like it simply
adds some leakiness in the negative part
of the function which helps resolve that
really units problem but there are also
some more advanced ways to do to
parameterize this function even the
parametric reloj which takes another
hyper parameter if we did not have
enough already the one that tries to
optimize what should be the leakiness of
the real function okay I told you like a
lot of stuff theoretically but what
should what can you take from this
lecture when you go and try to apply
this knowledge to to your neural nets
first of all I would strongly encourage
you to use rectified linear units this
is that activation function that has the
best performance but on the other hand
you should monitor for the fraction of
that units because this is the main
problem of this if the number of that
units it's too high you could probably
try to use lik ulo because this is the
one that resolves this problem I would
discourage you from using sigmoid
function as this is the the beginning of
the history a lot of disadvantages and
hyperbolic tangent is an alternative
it's sometimes can perform better but
most of the cases that the rectified
linear unit is the one you should go for
again comparing all the all the things I
said about
networks and activation functions in one
place so Sigma 8 saturated neurons not 0
Center small gradient and vanishing
gradient problem the hyperbolic tangent
resolves the issue of not 0 centered
data and it has a nice range of the
output but it still suffers from the
saturated neurons problem and the
rectified linear you need computational
efficiency accelerated convergence but
still that neurons and not 0 centered ok
here maybe more for posterity posterity
than for this this talk actually place
where you have all the activation
functions in one place and all the
gradients in one place you're probably
thinking that I omitted one of the
important activation function the
softmod softmax function it's actually
kind of a different function because
it's mainly used for categorization
problems it has nice properties because
it provides probability of a particular
category and it sums up two to one but
as I said it's like more to the output
layer than for the hidden layers okay so
now times for some experiments I told
you that reloj converges faster let's
show it in practice I'm not going to
tell you about the data it's the NIST
data probably all body knows everybody
knows this is the handwritten digits and
trying to recognize them so I trained
same architecture of the net same
learning rate all the parameters the
same except for the activation function
which I change in the hidden part of the
neural network and I'm comparing here
that the accuracy achieved by this these
three approaches let's maybe focus zoom
a bit to the to the beginning where the
actual differences happen so as we can
see maybe the difference when we look at
the lines is not so big but when
look in terms of like how fast do we
achieve a certain accuracy we can see
that one of the lines like achieve this
accuracy faster sorry for the small
labels the green one is the sigmoid
function the blue and the hyperbolic
tangent and the red one the rectified
linear unit okay when we do the same so
when we zoom at the end of the learning
rate no statistically significant
difference and summing this experiment
up when we look at the number of
iterations we need to reach a certain
accuracy we can see that hyperbolic
tangent and rectified linear you need
always like achieve this accuracy a bit
faster and I I'm always comparing to the
sigmoid value there's actually a sweet
spot around accuracy of 90% were
rectified linear you need does the job
five times faster when it comes to the
overall accuracy accuracy achieved as I
showed you there is no major difference
they ultimately arrive at the same
accuracy when it comes to the
computational time I was expecting to
actually see that reloj performs a bit
faster but maybe because I was
calculating this on my laptop it's why
there is no major difference okay
actually I did the same experiment but
using different type of data the text
data and it was Reuters data and
categorization problem so assigning
labels to two texts and again all three
functions compared here we can see that
the hyperbolic tangent actually
outperformed by a little the the
rectified linear you need but they are
pretty close anyway and the sigmoid
still being the the worst one the same
when we try to look at the loss of the
end of the net what I wanted to like
highlight here is that I think that the
rectified linear units try started to
overfit a bit faster
and did not achieve the same loss as the
hyperbolic tangent okay so all the
experiments that I showed here are
available like the code is available on
github you're more than welcome to come
and grab the code reuse it try to
experiment on your own I also encourage
you to visit a Facebook page data for
Poland it's a fan page for like-minded
people that know data science like to
talk about data science like sharing
problem solutions and so on and I also
strongly invite you to visit our stand
the lingers tent which is in that corner
of the Copernicus Science Center so
thank you very much in case you have
questions I'm more than welcome plans
for them here or at the booth we as you
prefer thank you
Thank You Dominic any questions for here
what's the difference between leaky
Aurelio and parametric value okay so
basically those are similar you can
think of this like in in terms of the
liquid has a constant parameter one that
you'll select a priori without any
knowledge so you simply based on your
experience or like some industry
standard you apply this number whereas
the leak ulo it's something that you try
to optimize as a hyper parameter so so
like for example with learning rate you
can select different learning rate right
and in this case you can select an
optimal leakiness of the reloj and
that's why it's parametric
any other questions are there any
disadvantages to using leaky raloo
because you mentioned disadvantages for
all the other ones but none for that one
like for now I think that it's the
safest approach as I said in terms of
reloj it's more experimental than
knowledge coming from Theory so yeah
basically I think this is the the the
best you can go for right now
I think that the question was about
problems with using Trello correct
like not problems in term of industry or
particular datatype more like problems
where you can see that the number of
debt neurons becomes like too high
compared to the total number of neurons
in your in your net
so this is like one thing that I would
monitor and if this number becomes too
high I would then try using something
different than the reloj are there any
other I don't know new exotic activation
functions that are out there that might
be promising in the future actually like
so many of them so it's hard to you know
list all of them I think I have seen a
nice blog post that was released last
week by deep learning quickly which had
like a long list of activation functions
like comparing all of those maybe you
can try to look there thank you very
much Thank You Dominic
you